ich ärgere mich auch obwohl ich versuche
mich ja nicht zu ärgern aber ich ärgere
mich wirklich über diesen corona
blindflug der politik ich meine die
politik ist hier ohne strategie und ohne
schwerpunkt unterwegs am anfang ist es
testen testen testen ist es masken
bringen nichts masken bringen nichts
maske bringen nichts dann ist es masken
husken masken dank lockdown lockdown
lockte schließlich impfen impfen da
durfte man nicht sagen dass die impfung
irgendwie auch nicht 100 prozent weg
jetzt sind wir bei boosten boosten
boosten plus masken slaughter und in
österreich sperren sie mittlerweile
schon karten k monarchie mäßig die
ungeimpften ein also die politik hier im
hamsterrad ihre mächtigen co mit
verrückten panik getriebenen politik und
ich glaube wir müssen uns jetzt langsam
über ausstiegsszenarien der gedanken
machen nur ganz kurz an dieser stelle
erstens die wichtigsten maßnahmen jetzt
die politik soll aufhören mit dieser
panikmache
zweites sachliche information auch
aufhören mit diesen propaganda übungen
im impfen man so die leute sachlich
informieren wer ist besonders gefährdet
wer muss sich impfen lassen aufhören mit
kinderimpfungen und solchen unsinn also
der staat muss sich langsam zurück
nehmen wegfall all diese einschränkungen
und am ende muss die regierung dafür
sorgen dass der einzelne der
eigenverantwortliche bürger all jene
informationen erhält um selber die
richtige entscheidung die vernünftige
entscheidung zu treffen für sich für die
gesellschaft
aufhören diese mit diesen coup des
buddhismus ich glaube geschlossen
ich bin sehr gespannt das statement hat
sich ja fast so angehört hat der staat
den plan für corona gehabt und würde
jetzt einfach darum herum aber wir sind
ja alle in diese pandemie
reingeschlittert wie man wusste wie sie
funktioniert dann konnte auch jemanden
masterplan haben natürlich vermisse ich
wünsche ich mir auch etwas mehr kohärenz
ja man sich anschaut wie am 16
bundesländern die entscheiden dass alle
selbständig haben das teilweise sehr
sehr individuell gemacht und das trägt
nicht dazu bei sollte sich sicher fühlen
dass ich gut informiert fühlen dass die
maßnahmen zu einander passen ja und
deshalb finde ich schon dass wir auch in
zukunft gucken sollten dann wieder
krisen haben diese art zu internationale
führungs kapazität haben das auch von
der bundesebene geführt werden kann und
wenn nicht in jedem bundesland in jedem
landkreis die maßnahme selber
entscheiden auch wenn man natürlich mal
lokal differenzieren muss aber ansonsten
wir haben auch andere impfungen die
pflicht sind die vom staatlichen gesagt
im werbung und europa gerade die
masernimpfung die einen kindergärten und
schulen pflicht ist ich meine ich meine
diese impfung aber es gibt ein ganzes im
programm ja auch für säuglinge quasi was
was empfohlen wird und was gemacht
werden soll und deshalb für mich also
nicht finde ich nicht falsch wenn der
staat eine impfung empfiehlt zumal sich
um einfach eine krankheit immer eine
pandemie handelt die ist gesellschafts
gefährlich und gegen die musterstadt
auch angehen sondern muss es da auch in
gewissen nachdruck geben aber wo ich ein
recht gäbe ist der punkt jeder bürger
sollte alleine entscheiden was ich eben
lässt ich bin gegen die impfpflicht
außer in den bereichen wo wirklich
schutzbefohlene sich aufhalten die sich
nicht wehren können in altenheim in
krankenhäuser und so weiter sollten
würde ich darüber nachdenken ob man hier
empfiehlt ein willkommen wir doch zu
einer aktion am koalitionsverhandlung wo
er auch die fdp ist heute gab so etwas
wie er war erst hat die ampel schon
beschlossen dass es die impfpflicht in
bestimmten bereichen gibt dann ist vor
gericht noch mal vor die kamera gegangen
wie sieht es denn die bundesvorsitzende
jungen liberalen solltest die
impfpflicht in bestimmten bereichen
geben also erstmal möchte ich sagen ich
muss leider einmal ganz widersprechen
natürlich hat die bundesregierung um
geehrt und zwar massiv wenn man von
anfang an eine ganz deutliche im
strategie gefahren wäre ich bin heute
durch berlin gelaufen in den ganzen tag
ich habe kein einziges mal werbung fürs
impfen gesehen ich habe keine
möglichkeit gehabt einfach irgendwo
anzugehen mich impfen zu lassen
natürlich hat die bundesliga
total rom gehört beim thema testen ich
war heute in das ist das freut mich sehr
dass nicht gut ich finde jeder sollte
sich ein und das hat sich sehr gut an
ich warte ich testen und ich habe erst
in der schlange gestanden und danach
musste ich über setzen weil er eine frau
war die konnte nur spanisch und nur
englisch und die person konnte nur durch
sie konnte sich und ihr kind nicht
testen lassen und ich finde das ist ein
ganz großes problem und die
bundesregierung hatte monatelang zeit
gehabt das zu ändern da konkret dagegen
anzugehen in großbritannien ist das so
da kann jeder bürger jederzeit jeden tag
100 es bestimmt schnell dass die welt
nach hause geliefert ganz einfach wir
müssen erst einen termin machen dann
müssen wir irgendwo hingehen wir haben
nur einmal die woche die möglichkeit
nicht zulassen warum der staat hatte von
anfang an ein interesse daran dass alle
menschen sich testen lassen ein
bekannter von mir der hat die it
infrastruktur aufgebaut im zentrum und
dann wieder abgebaut obwohl wir doch
alle wussten man öfter tätig galt von
anfang an rufer anja das irgendwann
gebucht werden muss ich finde das war
ein absolutes roman und ich finde das
ist der grund dass die letzte
bundesregierung so versagt hat mit
diesem thema dass die jetzige
bundesregierung oder die eventuell sich
bald bildende leider wieder über die
gleichen maßnahmen sprechen
ich glaube das muss man sehr stark ab
werden ich bin mir sicher dass die fdp
sich nicht als erster quasi dafür
einsetzen wird das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen aber man muss immer kommst du
natürlich ein kompromiss zu schaffen
christian lindner die fdp wir haben
nicht die absolute mehrheit erreicht man
wein in der demokratie braucht ist eben
kompromisse und ich glaube jeder weiß
von christian endler und karl lauterbach
an einem tisch setzen dann kommt ja auf
jeden fall kommt karl lauterbach über
seine eine ganz kurze sache erstmal
müssen wir uns fragen was wäre denn wenn
jetzt weiter die groko regieren würde
und da bin ich mir sicher würden wir
einfach nur noch wieder beim lockt
ansprechen
parteien sagen wir machen eben kein
locker und wir machen und maßnahmen wir
lassen uns nur anders
und machen aber regionale londons und
zwar gegen ganz deutschland bestimmt
nicht aber das wird doch diese maßnahme
ist es nicht mehr enthalten also es gibt
keine rechtliche grundlage mehr einen
lockout zu verhängen es gibt alle
möglichen anderen möglichkeiten 2g 3g
masken pflichten abstandsregeln aber es
gibt kein lockdown doktorgrades hier
diskutiert haben das arbeitsverbot gibt
was geschäfte schließen müssen sie
beschließen müssen weitere
beschränkungen haben sie wieder mit
aufgenommen das sollte ja erst nicht
drin sein im gesetzentwurf auf druck der
union jetzt wieder reingekommen also sie
sind schon sehr dicht wieder daran und
sie haben gesehen in den vergangenen
tagen dass dieser weg deutschland aus
der epidemischen notlage zu befreien
dass das politisch offenbar eine
schnapsidee war das hat die mehrheit der
bevölkerung nicht mitgetragen sie
konnten sich nicht durchsetzen als
frischgebackener ampel das war ein
richtiger strategischer fehler von ihnen
allen in der ampel also wie gesagt ich
glaube man muss erstmal darüber sprechen
warum sind wir wieder an dieser gleichen
situation liefert sie monaten und das
ist die alte und immer noch übrigens
geschäftsführende im amt bestehen der
bundesregierung und das ist der
eigentliche skandal und deshalb dass
jetzt die neuen ampel partner darüber
sprechen müssen wie geht man in einer
sehr extrem situation jetzt damit um
dass wir nicht ein paar schade da sich
ganz klar die schuld bei der letzten
bundesregierung und schreitende punkt in
dieser ganzen debatte ich meine das mit
allem respekt vor diesen
innenpolitischen verschiebe reihen wir
sind jetzt in einem zustand wesentlich
verfassungsmäßig garantierte grundrechte
der menschen einfach mal so mir nichts
dir nichts außer kraft gesetzt werden in
einem was in österreich abgeht das ist
ja wirklich unglaublich wir steuern auf
diese situation hier auch zu sie haben
es gesagt mit den ganzen lokalen
geschichte ich sage etwas vom
wichtigsten des staatlichen handelns ist
immer die verhältnismäßigkeit wo ist
eigentlich jede verhältnismäßigkeit ich
habe heute die zahlen geschafft für für
die schweiz und da habe ich gesehen wie
tot das medianalter in der schweiz jetzt
und ich will das nicht bagatellisieren
jeder tote wenn man so will ist einer
zuviel das im familientragödien damit
ich überhaupt nichts das verharmlosen
das medianalter ist 89 jahre
89 jahre das heißt 50 prozent aller mit
cupid gestorbenen sind über 89 50
prozent unter 89 mit dem spezifischen
alter schwerpunkt zwischen vielleicht 83
bis 89 die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung in der schweiz ist 84
das heißt wir haben eine klar
berechenbare
risikogruppe was macht die politik sie
verschwendet ihre energie im sinne von
möglichst viele impfen auch die jungen
die gar kein risiko haben für die alten
hat man dann zu wenig booster impfungen
aus angst vor den impfgegnern hat man
nichts gewagt zusagen über die
nachlassende wirkung der impfungen mit
dem effekt dass seit sommer die
geimpften senioren frei herumlaufen im
glauben sie seien voll geschützt sind
sie aber nicht sie liegen jetzt auf den
intensivstationen und da sage ich also
militärisch gesprochen in der führung
müssen sie immer ein schwerpunkt bilden
sie müssen einen akzent setzen sie
können nicht einfach mit einem
flächenbombardement der im propaganda
versuchen auch die 20-jährigen eben die
beschläge impfen wollen sich noch in
billionen impfen das ist doch keine sau
rausgelassen allein dadurch läuft das
wenn sie nach dänemark wo 92 pro die
politik beschlossen mit mit dir
traumwert dort haben wir keine probleme
dort haben wir wesentlich weniger
probleme und wir sehen auch in schleswig
holstein war auch über 90 prozent
geimpft sind ist die weniger todesfälle
weniger neuinfektionen haben und dass
leute das zeigt sich impfen nützt was
und sie haben vom doktor angesprochen
diesellok tor wird es nicht geben mit
den anderen parteien er steht nicht im
gesetzentwurf
das sind falsche informationen oktober
wird es dann wirklich mehr geben naja
wenn sie das wort nie mehr das wohl nie
mehr ob ich mir den der korona
was ich mir wünschen würde dass sie ist
schaffen den deutschen das
selbstbewusstsein zurückzugeben eine
krise zu bewältigen weil das ist uns
verloren gegangen in dieser pandemie wir
haben panische warnung erhalten
eigentlich im minutentakt von markus
söder von karl lauterbach von vielen
anderen robert veloster robert wiler der
jetzt sagt
es ist lothar wieler es ist fünf nach
zwölf mittlerweile ist es alles zu spät
würde ja bedeuten es lohnt sich gar
nicht mehr sie können ihr handel
einstellen in der ampel ist es sowieso
zu spät solche warnungen müssen wir uns
stündlich täglich anhören seit zwei
jahren mittlerweile und da würde ich mir
wünschen dass sie den deutschen das
selbstbewusstsein zurück und lassen wir
es jetzt bei dem thema sache klarstellen
wie auf den intensivstationen liegen
nicht die geimpften deren schutz
nachlassen die ungeimpften und dass man
sich eine euro du hast nur zwei dagegen
halten
zur einschätzung der fakten drost gesagt
das fand ich sehr richtig wir haben es
ist ein irrglaube man europa und wir
haben eine panne haben nicht nur eine
panne und im kleist noch noch sechs
monate
ich würde auch liebend gern weiter
demontieren